leïla qui valent à roulotter le
directeur général raphaël mariano grossi
de la nouvelle agence internationale de
l'énergie atomique
lui très longue
à la ja nous travaillons en permanence
ici le vice directeur général pour la
sécurité avec son équipe ils ont
travaillé toute la nuit
au vu des circonstances
en ukraine
en bref
il avait peut-être certaines
informations
ce que je peux vous dire
c'est des informations confirmées qui
viennent
au du régulateur ukrainiens
ou directement du de la centrale
nucléaire de zappa rhodia ou sommes en
contact avec eux en permanence et nous
l'avons été toute la nuit
comme vous avez été informé dans la nuit
un projectile a touché un bâtiment
au sein de
l'enceinte de la centrale
ce bâtiment
ne fait pas partie du réacteur
aucun des réacteurs
ne touche
ce bâtiment
cela a entraîné un feu localisé
qui a été éteint par
par les pompiers locaux
sur le site
tous les systèmes de sécurité
des six réacteurs
du site n'ont pas été affectés aucun
du tout
il n'y a pas eu de rejet de matières de
matière radioactive
est un système de suivi de la radiation
qui permet de mesurer la radiation la
radioactivité tout cela fonctionne bien
également
cependant comme vous l'imaginez
l'opérateur et le régulateur
nous disent que la situation
continue à être très intense et
dangereuse à cause de circonstances
concernant l'unité des réacteurs
dans toutes les unités que nous avons
sur place il y en a qu'une qui
fonctionne à 60% de ses capacités
l'unité 1 ne fonctionne plus pour
maintenance de la deux et la trois
sont
éteints pour contrôles de sécurité
l'unité 4 fonctionne 60% unités 5 et 6
étaient déjà en réserve et fonctionner à
une puissance réduite
deux personnes ont été blessées
d'après nos informations
ce ne sont pas des opérateurs ou des
personnels techniques
ils font partie de du personnel de
sécurité
de la centrale
voilà les faits nous sommes en contact
avec les opérateurs
et nous suivons la situation de très
près
comment réagit son nom quelles sont les
mesures que nous allons potentiellement
prendre au vu des circonstances
comme vous le savez
il ya quelques jours
nous avons eu une session spéciale du
conseil des gouverneurs ici
lors de cette session
j'ai indiqué en plus des appels
pour rappeler
le principe de ne pas attaquer des sites
nucléaires
et d'autres éléments conceptuels
importants
j'ai aussi rappelé aux états membres
d'un certain nombre
de points très clair
que l'on ne doit jamais compromettre
il faut assurer la sécurité et la sûreté
de toutes les centrales nucléaires que
ce soit un réacteur où un autre site
le premier point c'était l'intégrité
physique
d'un réacteur
de déchets radioactifs
etc
deuxième point
le système de sécurité et de sûreté
doivent tous continuer à fonctionner le
troisième point le personnel doit être
en capacité de remplir ses fonctions
normalement quatrièmement
à tout moment il doit y avoir une
puissance hors site de l'électricité
pour que laisse le site puisse continuer
à fonctionner normalement
j'ai parlé de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement qui doit être
disponible en cas de besoin
des pièces de rechange qui peuvent être
nécessaires pour des réparations
et le sixième point
le suit le suivi de la radioactivité
qui doivent fonctionner pour savoir ce
qu'il se passe
savoir s'il ya potentiellement de la
radioactivité
enfin la communication qui est très
importante nous n'avons vu cette nuit
sans quoi il aurait été impossible de
confirmer
ce que nous vous disions
tout le monde
sans exception
est d'accord on dire tous les pays à ce
que ces principes doivent être maintenus
cependant
l'intégrité physique le premier point de
du site a été
compromise avec ce qu'il s'est passé
la nuit dernière
heureusement
il n'ya pas eu de rejet de radioactivité
l'intégrité des réacteurs
n'a pas été compromise
mais c'est nous convenons de ces
principes les paroles doivent avoir un
sens
nous devons agir conformément à ce
principe la i20
doit donc désormais agir
nous devons faire quelque chose
l'ukraine envoyé une demande d aide
immédiate à nous
au vu de ce qu'il se passe
et des risques
que nous courons si cela continue
sans amélioration sans un nouvel
engagement envers ses principes
j'ai indiqué à la fédération de russie
et à l'ukraine
que je suis disponible
pour me rendre à tchernobyl dès que
possible
afin que ces sept piliers clés ne soit
plus compromis
l'idée de cette initiative
en tant que directeur général de l'aeia
et de convenir d'un cadre et d'un
compromis
qui permette de préserver ses principes
auxquels nous sommes engagés
nous savons que vu la situation qui est
très compliquée sur le terrain la
logistique de ce voyage pour que je me
rende dans hp
ne sera pas facile
et dans le même temps
je ne pense pas que ce soit impossible
si nous devons apporter une aide nous
devons être sur place en tant que chef
de la n va je dois être sur place
j'aimerais clarifier un point cette
initiative de ma part
n'est ce pas
politique
ce n'est pas mon mandat
je ne suis pas le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu ni le secrétaire général de l'onu
ni un médiateur autoproclamé
je le dis clairement
il s'agit ici d'établir un cadre sous
l'égide de la e1
qui permettent à l'ue à l'ukraine et aux
forces présentes
ce dans le contexte de cette opération
militaire de la fédération de russie
de convenir d'un engagement à ne pas
compromettre
ses principes
que j'ai mentionnés
voilà les faits donc
la demande l'aide a été soumise à notre
organisation ne l'ignorons pas je suis
prêt à venir
je m'en tiens là et je vais prendre vos
questions
pouvez vous expliquer avec qui avez-vous
été en contact côté russe
vous avez parlé du régulateur ukrainiens
et ce qu'on sait
si le les centrales nucléaires est
contrôlée par les forces russes ou est
ce que les ukrainiens continue à
contrôler le site
comme je les dis je suis en contact
avec la russie et l'ukraine bien sûr
l'ukraine est le partenaire naturel nous
parlons de l'ukraine bien évidemment
mais nous savons ce n'est pas un secret
il y à une opération militaire et les
forces russes sont présentes nous sommes
en contact avec la fédération de russie
au niveau diplomatique et technique
deuxièmement
concernant
mais la salle de contrôle
du
ac tuellement il n'y a que le personnel
l'ukrainien qui gère les opérations
ce matin à 10h45
à tchernobyl et à sa part au chien
il y à un contrôle effectif du site
par les forces militaires russes
j'espère que vous comprenez la
différence entre les deux
vous proposer un cadre
pour garantir la sûreté
du site de la part des deux parties
quel est le lien avec tchernobyl est ce
que voulait négocier à tchernobyl
nous allons partager
des éléments avec les deux sites
nous allons essayer de convenir
de ce principe nous devons avoir des
consultations
donc l'objectif est de négocier oui
qui de sera votre partenaire de
négociation ce sont souvent des les
ministres de des affaires extérieures
est ce que vous voulez que les deux
ministres des deux pays se rencontrent
je parle des autorités politiques du
pays
c'est une situation sans précédent
normalement on diplomatie la solution
c'est de se tourner vers le président
c'est ce que l'on avait fait la dernière
fois que ça s'est passé
ce qui crée une pratique une tradition
mais ici nous sommes dans une situation
inédite
et ce qui est au coeur de cette
initiative c'est le besoin d'agir
et de répondre à ceux de à cette demande
des dents en sachant la réalité sur le
terrain
est ce que vous savez qui est
responsable
du projectile qui a touché le site les
forces l'ukrainienne ou russes
qu'est ce que les russes vous ont dit
sur le fait d'envoyer une équipe
pour apporter une aide que pense-t-il de
votre idée d'une visite
merci
ce projectile d'après ce que nous savons
venez des forces russes
nous n'avons pas de détails sur le type
de projectiles dont il s'agit
c'est ce que nous savons
quant à la visite
les deux sites envisagent cette
possibilité
deux questions
que se passe-t-il à sa part au chien
vous avez dit que les ukrainiens étaient
dans la salle de contrôle du contrôle
les opérations mais ils sont entourés
par les forces russes
que va-t-il se passer selon vous
est-ce que ça va resté gelé un tel quel
comme à tchernobyl ou autre chose
pour revenir sur ce qui a été dit
si vous n'avez pas d'accord pour une
réunion pourquoi est ce que vous
suggérez une visite à tchernobyl
il a des questions techniques ce qui
qui m'encourage à me rendre là bas
pour mieux comprendre la situation
et être plus efficace diplomatiquement
c'est très important d'être sur place
bien sûr
il y aura peut-être différents formats
possibles ce que nous souhaitons indiqué
c'est que nous sommes prêts à la
faire quelque chose au vu de ce qu'il se
passe et pas simplement d'envoyer des
tweets ou de dire des choses d'ici nous
sommes prêts à nous déplacer
tout est lié vous savez
nouvelle situation qui est très
difficile à maintenir
ce qu'il s'est passé ça ce n'est
nous le trou
je le dis depuis quelques jours je suis
préoccupé
cette situation est très fragile
instable
et nous avons vu ce maintenant que à
cause de l'impact d'un projectile
on sait pas comment ça s'est passé
même s'il y avait une équipe qui
enquêtait sur place ce serait impossible
à déterminer
en tout cas on arrivé à cette situation
qui aurait pu être dramatique
je pense qu'il ne faut pas attendre
que ce genre de choses arrive
avant les essayer de répondre de manière
plus efficace car nous savons ce qui est
en jeu
c'est pas de la situation cette nuit que
vous êtes en contact avec les personnes
sur place
donc il ya eu un projet que tu vois là
pour cette allocution du directeur
général de l'aïe e à l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
agence qui dépend de l'onu